so why don't we start why don't we start
with you Amanda tell me what drew you to
Stanford you've lived in the Middle East
you were at Dartmouth which is a far
different place than Stanford what made
you come out to Stanford sure well when
I was at when I was living in Bahrain I
actually came to Stanford when I was 17
for an International Baccalaureate camp
and I knew that at one point in my life
I needed to come back to the school I
absolutely fell in love with it I fell
in love with the fact that you can be
both laid-back and productive at the
same time and the collaborative nature
of the school the community that the
school provides for you and the close
tight-knit relationship that you
actually have with your professors once
you're there and all of that was a gut
instinct at the time because I was 17
how did I know that I was going to end
up at the GSB but you know going through
you know my Dartmouth experience I
wanted something very similar to that
but in a grad school where I was able to
form really meaningful relationships and
I have to say that every alum that I
hadn't met I was absolutely impressed
with and absolutely loved and I said you
know what I want to be part of this
community so maybe a little less snow
I'm interested in who has affected you
during your time at Stanford have you
met an individual a faculty member or
student a fellow student that's really
shaped or changed your time Amanda sure
I would have to say that almost
everybody I meet and not to sound cliche
or anything but the diversity of
perspectives that the Business School is
amazing and I have to say I learned
something new from everybody I encounter
there and that's just added to the
richness of my life more specifically I
can point to a faculty member bhavish
shiv who teaches marketing there and I
came from analyzing tech media telco
investments and I know that I have a
love for new media and he's a marketing
professor and I told him you know what I
really want to go through and do
something within digital marketing and
he was just very supportive and told me
you know what I have this startup who
was
looking for somebody to you know do an
independent study for them so that you
can maybe get your feet wet and really
just dig your hands into into a project
so he helped introduce me to the CEO and
I'm doing that independent study next
term so I'm very excited about that and
he's just helped me open some doors both
externally and internally so that's
great
Amanda how about surprises have you
found anything did you discover anything
along in your time so far that was
different than what you might have
expected positive or negative we can go
either way
well I think there was a lot of
reinforcement and so I think it was more
so the degree to which what I was
feeling was actually really confirmed at
the school so this is sort of a bit
positive and negative so about a year
ago a little over a year ago now
unfortunately we lost a couple of
classmates and it was it was amazing how
much of a sense of community there was
at the GSB around that and I mean
Derrick Bolton our admissions officer
was in tears talking about how much
these students meant to him and to the
school and how much you know they meant
to us and it was just so touching I have
to say and I don't think that I would
have ever been able to experience that
at any other school I've never heard of
anything like that happening at any
other school where you know we all get
together we've only known these people
who you know may they rest in peace
we only use them for a couple of weeks
but the intense bonds that we had formed
already with these people was I mean
that just shed a light on that just how
quickly you truly become have meaningful
relationships it really forms the
community I was telling the freshmen
when I sit out in the quad every year at
Reunion we sit out for dinner on the
quad and my wife and I usually sit with
the 50th reunion class and it's by
people who formed they're best friends
when they were undergraduates and
they've known these people for all this
time and it's a remarkably strong bond
it absolutely is lifelong friends yes
exactly right exactly right Amanda what
would you tell them about why should
they think about coming to a place like
Stanford what would you tell them well I
came from across the globe I guess it
and I have to say it's been one of the
most exciting experiences of my life and
I would do it all over again and I'm
really glad that I still have a few more
months to go before I have to at least
leave the university I'm not entirely
sure whether or not I'm staying in
Silicon Valley or not it's all going to
depend on career options but I say take
the leap because it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity you know
when you're doing your due diligence on
schools just look at the things that
matter most to you and why which is you
know what the business school asks of
people is to really be introspective
about what matters most to you and why
in the application process and then from
there sometimes you know people realize
oh there are some things that matter to
me and they are in line with Stanford's
culture or they're not right so if you
really feel that you belong to a school
I think no matter how far it is you
should definitely go out and go for it
so yeah once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
yeah